[Music]
there are some would make me out to be
the villain
of this here
good thing story
[Music]
are you born with destiny
or does it just come
a young singer from memphis tennessee
give him a warm hayride welcome
[Music]
mr elvis presley
get a haircut buttercup
in that moment
i watched that skinny boy transform
into a superhero
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he was my destiny
i wish to promote you mr presley
are you ready to fly i'm ready ready to
fly
tomorrow all america will be talking
about this question
[Music]
they might put me in jail for walking
across the street but you're a famous
white boy
what are you saying is god-given so
there can't be nothing wrong with it
senator kennedy
martin luther king has been shot to
death in memphis that's all right for
you tragedy but it has nothing to do
with us it has everything to do with us
[Music]
and nobody's gonna remember me
[Music]
i need to get back to who i really am
and how are you
[Applause]
oz i just gotta be making the most of
this thing what i can
this can all be over the flesh
[Music]
we are the same you and i
we are two odd lonely children reaching
for eternity
the greatest show on earth
elvis has left the building
[Music]
you